hi this is jonathan rotz field
agronomist pioneer i'm back here today
in this same cover crop field that we
had earlier and you can see it's still
green and growing now some folks may say
that a cover crop this size is way too
big to worry about planting through and
there are some challenges that come
along with it but just as a lot of
producers that i work with have found
out there are ways to get through this
and there's actually some benefits down
the road as well more on that in some
later videos cover crops have a lot of
benefits including soil preservation
carbon sequestration increased organic
matter in soils
both nutrient creation and retention and
many more
however as we try to maximize some of
these benefits we can also create
management challenges for the crop this
first challenge we meet in the spring is
at planting time this video will
highlight how some producers are working
to manage through some of these
challenges
the first challenge we come to is simply
planting through this amount of biomass
as discussed last time some of this
starts in the fall by not planting your
cover crop very heavy to make sure that
biomass is manageable about one bushel
of small grain is enough
many producers who have adopted planting
into large cover are also using some
form of rolling to lay the cover down
before or at planting
these rollers not only push the cover
down but they also crimp the cover
this helps so that the cover crop will
not stand back up as well as starting
the process of decomposition and
nutrient release by keeping the cover
crop in contact with the soil
in this scenario this crop was sprayed
with herbicide just prior to rolling
the next part is to make sure that your
planter is set up to not wrap the cover
crop while still making a good zone for
the seed to be planted into including
proper closing of the seed trench
many options are available for planters
that can work in these scenarios but
discussing these options with others who
are having success is a great place to
start
when planting into cover crops either
make sure the crop is dead and somewhat
dry or live and growing
these are the two best ways to manage
the cover crop so your planter does not
have issues cutting through the cover
creating hair pinning in the furrow
when a cover crop is in the process of
dying it can be hard to cut through
of course planting into cover is also no
different than any other planting that
you must make sure that the soil is dry
many have found that a live active
growing cover crop will actually help
pull moisture out of the soil whereas a
dead cover will keep soils wet once the
cover crop is rolled and planted through
you now have a nice mat of biomass that
will keep soil moisture in as well as
help to compete with weeds
this biomass will break down over time
re-releasing nutrition to the growing
crop
now interestingly enough right between
these two fields we're seeing some
differences in some cover crops this is
mainly due to both species and planting
date but it brings up the interesting
observation of what happens whenever we
have different sizes of cover crops and
this all comes back to general agronomy
and carbon to nitrogen ratios as we get
larger and larger cover we have more
stem elongation and more of those
proteins are put into the head
production as well as grain this means
we're going to have a lower nitrogen or
a higher carbon to nitrogen ratio this
will be slower to die and decompose over
the year
smaller covers on the other side will
have higher carbon to nitrogen and will
be quicker to disappear throughout the
year again we'll see more about this on
later videos this mat of material is a
good thing but it can also make it
difficult to get nitrogen to the growing
crop early on as it breaks down
because it has a lot of carbon to
decompose because of this i like to have
a significant amount of nitrogen put
down with the planter into the soil
below the cover crop to carry the crop
to side dress time
although planting through large cover
may not be for everyone i hope that this
has at least highlighted how some are
making it work i hope this video has
given you some things to consider if you
are thinking about changing your cover
cropping practices
as always talk to those who are already
doing this to get some tips and tricks
and when trying different things start
in small stages to see what's best for
your operation
thanks for your time and i hope you
found this video informative and helpful
we'll continue to return to this
operation and field to highlight some of
the benefits we can see with cover crops
throughout this season so keep an eye
out for more videos like this
that concludes this pioneer agronomy
video podcast visit our page on
pioneer.com and follow us on twitter and
facebook for more agronomy insights